e aí
o conhecem moçambique sempre que foi faz
um dos vídeos se um país que de norte
alguma ao sul de maputo tem cerca de
três mil quilômetros é um país em que
mais de metade da população vive abaixo
do limiar de pobreza é um país em cerca
de dois terços da população vive da
agricultura de subsistência o que
significa que é a seca ou se a chuva não
a colheita a fome é um país em que mais
de metade da população a cerca de metade
da população apenas direito a
alfabetização e percebe alguma coisa que
ler e de escrever em que um terço das
mulheres apenas saber ler ou escrever e
é um país em que aproximadamente
cinquenta por cento mais metade não tem
acesso direto água potável
nós temos um pequeno exercício de
comparação entre o nosso país moçambique
e afinal de contas moçambique 30 milhões
de fogo
em portugal é um país em que a taxa de
mortalidade infantil é seguramente 70
vezes superior à nossa é um país em que
a esperança média de vida é feita de
metade da nossa e é um país em que o pib
per capta é 20 vezes superior ao nosso
esse é um país em que cada mulher tem em
média cinco a seis filhos sendo que para
além da taxa de mortalidade infantil ser
brutal expectativa média de vida é curta
o que significa ter pirâmide daquele
país é traduzida por mais de metade da
população de menos de 15 a virgindade
oi e para essa população de cerca de 30
milhões de habitantes em que mais metade
tem menos de 15 habilidade a quantidade
de profissionais de saúde concretamente
da classe médica das diferentes
realidades na ultrapassa 12 dígitos
comparativamente a portugal onde em
média é de três a quatro dígitos por
exemplo para cerca de 15 milhões de
crianças e adolescentes com menos de 15
anos a 89 pediatras no país inteiro com
3 mil quilómetros de comprimento
o final de quem é a famosa eles famosos
nasceu em 2013 e nasceu do repto do
então reitor de uma universidade uma das
maiores universidades e centros de saúde
país que partilhou com um grupo de
profissionais portugueses a sua angústia
relativamente à qualidade da formação em
saúde dos profissionais como sabe que
quer aníbal de formação pré-escolar
académica que é a nível de formação
diferenciada e afinal de contas esse
redutor partilhou essa angústia pedindo
ajuda e o que esse grupo de médicos
assumiu foi que não podia ficar em
frente e não podia guardar o
conhecimento a competência ea
qualificação para si e tem obrigação
humana deontológica e profissional de
partilhar e foi assim que esse grupo de
médicos assumiu que com base na
solidariedade científica no total regime
de voluntariado colaborar com moçambique
e colaborar na
tá perdoada na capacitação de
profissionais como único objetivo da
competências criar capacidades forma a
melhorar a prestação de cuidados de
saúde a oração e o nosso lema é sobre
grade científica como sambique sendo que
desde 2013 e aos famosos tem vindo a
crescer e até à data realizamos 24
missões no terreno e essas 24 emissões
envolveram mais de 100 profissionais
português de diferentes áreas do
conhecimento formaram no terreno mais de
2.500 alunos medicina medicina dentária
de enfermagem de nutrição formaram no
terreno mais de 3 mil profissionais
destas diferentes áreas do conhecimento
e formar mais e farão cerca de 86
formados
o presente em várias áreas e formamos de
norte a sul do país desde a medicina
dentária dentista de todo o país que era
uma formação teórica que era uma função
teórica ou prática prática um um ombro
com doente temos a preocupação porque
somos suportados na academia de fazer
uma formação com qualificação que
permite a esses profissionais não só
sentir envolvido porque a vontade tem de
aprender é brutal é capacidade de
encontrar em conhecimento e os ajuda a
melhorar as suas competências que é que
é extremamente difícil o que significa
que incentivamos e vamos formação de
qualidade de forma a melhorar as suas
competências temos a preocupação de
fazer um tipo de formação que permita a
aplicação até a aquisição das
competências completas e a simulação é
uma forma que usamos frequentemente para
ensinar não apenas a simulação mas
também depois o treino ombro a ombro
porque o que complementa o trem da
simulação prática em saúde
materno-infantil que tem um país de
gente jovem em cuidados neonatais porque
a taxa de natalidade
é brutal e a taxa de mortalidade também
e formação por exemplo numa área que não
existem moçambique por incrível um país
que uma relação pediátrica brutal com
uma prevalência de acidentes enorme e
não ensina cirurgia pediátrica um país
com a prevalência brutal de malformações
e não tem informação e cirurgiões
pediátricos uma das áreas que começando
por hellern e depois trabalhando no
ensino do terreno aí aos famosos
envolveu fazer um país com outra
particularidade fala se muita
malnutrição por desnutrição associada à
pobreza associada à dificuldade do
acesso ao alimento e a baixo a baixo
nível cultural mas é um país
caracteristicamente em transição
nutricional é que se por um lado há uma
prevalência brutal de maldição por
descrição também é uma prevalência
crescente das doenças não comunicáveis
de diabetes doença cardiovascular do
cancro entre outros e assim a formação
em diabetes a formação em doença
cardiovascular tem sido uma das nossas
preocupações outra área e nós vamos
sempre
e daquilo que os profissionais nos pedem
e daquilo que nós vamos conhecendo do
país e achamos que tem cabimento
desenvolver outra área muito trabalhada
é a área da cirurgia ambulatória num
país com patologia cirúrgica abundante
com carência de recursos técnicos e
humanos é importante agilizar a
prestação de cuidados e criar unidades
cirurgia ambulatório do norte a sul do
país nos hospitais de referência foi um
dos nossos pontos trabalho que neste
momento já permitiu a criação de duas
unidades em deus a fitagem centrais
cirurgia oftalmológica a catarata é uma
das principais causas de perda de visão
com implicações brutais do dia a dia da
população e afinal de contas é de fácil
resolução os dias dores e depois para
além desta vertente formativa
pré-graduada ou especializada temos uma
preocupação brutal de capacitar os
cuidados primários de saúde ensinar os
técnicos ensinar os enfermeiros que
ensinar os médicos irem ao encontro da
população e fazerem algo que é crucial
em qualquer país em particular um país
diz que é prevenção primária e então
a saúde em colaboração direta com os
profissionais temos trabalhado é
prevenção fortemente nomeadamente no que
diz respeito não apenas a doenças
infecciosas mestre as doenças não
publicadas inclusive elaborando
ferramentas que distribuímos a população
adaptadas e adequadas à realidade
cultural e socioeconômica do país outro
aspecto de que nos orgulhamos fortemente
foi a promoção a nível nacional com base
nas faculdades e dentária de um sistema
de vigilância de saúde oral and vascular
este sistema de vigilância permite não
apenas rastrear patologia nomeadamente
cáries em crianças escolares o que
significa atuar uma fase muito precoce
mas tivemos o privilégio de ensinar
tendo o apoio deste professor holandês
uma forma simples de tratamento de cárie
dentária em uma mesa de uma escola feita
por profissionais de saúde e que permite
de uma forma não dura rosa não
traumática mas altamente eficaz resolver
uma das doenças doenças mais prevalentes
nesta população
e sendo que para além desta intervenção
a nível de formação e de comunidade e as
famosas também tem tido outra
preocupação que é criar partilhas de
experiências entre profissionais
moçambicanos e portugueses e assim
incentivamos e apoiamos não apenas
estágios de moçambicanos profissionais
em portugal mas sobretudo estágios de
internos portugueses em formação
específica em instituições moçambique
para permitir em ter um contato com uma
realidade em termos de cuidados de saúde
que aqui foi escrita que não tem nada a
ver ele por pelo estava anteriormente
que não tem nada a ver com a nossa
realidade e que nos permite pensar e
confrontar com situações que não cidade
são raras em portugal o interno
pediatria eu falo da pediatria porque a
área de conheço melhor é confrontado com
a morte em uma situação excepcional em
cuidados intensivos pediátricos em
cuidados neonatais excepcionalmente mas
em moçambique é confrontado com a morte
diariamente e não uma nem duas nem três
pessoas
e em 2018 foi o ano em que tivemos uma
atividade incrível durante todo o ano
caracterizado que temos um profissional
de saúde pelo menos o ano inteiro em
moçambique desenvolvendo uma série de
atividades dentro do âmbito que acabei
de descrever como disse toda nossa
atividade a atividade para o 1 ano
volume pode fazer a nacionalidade
científica somos apoiados por mecenas
que confiam na nossa na nossa missão mas
também temos tentado fazer algo que está
intenso as características do médico é
fazer o link entre a medicina a
sociedade médica e a sua carreira
artística porque o médico quer ficar
aqui elas profissionais de saúde em
geral tem uma vertente uma veia
artística temos o primeiro ano passado
contar com a primeira visita a portugal
da orquestra américa do mundo uma festa
sinfônica constituída apenas por médicos
do mundo inteiro pela primeira vez em
portugal a realizar dois concertos no
país e temos o privilégio também de dois
em dois anos e estava existirá de novo
realizar uma coletiva de artistas
solidários
os famosos que reúne mais de tinta nomes
alto gabarito na arte portuguesa e
moçambicana aqui dentro que a
preocupação que temos sempre é fazer
informação de qualidade formação de
referência formação que permita mudar
atitudes molhar a competências e
melhorar a saúde no país e para isso
temos o apoio ea retaguarda em termos de
acreditação das diferentes instituições
quer em portugal quer em prática e 2019
aconteceu o vídeo o idai que como todos
se recordam destruiu três províncias do
centro de moçambique
e por isso fala a verdade única e
aparência da zambézia causou graves
danos a população e nas estruturas após
uma noite de mais de 12 horas no ventos
ciclónicos mais de 300km da hora choveu
torrencialmente durante dois a três dias
o que causou inundações e distribuições
gravíssima nesta zona beira é uma cidade
muito particular capital da província
pesada tem a característica de estar
localizada a cerca de dois metros abaixo
do nível do mar na confluência de três
rios e ficou praticamente inundada e
para além da beira ou melhor a cidade e
sim mas particularmente hospital da
beira que homens uma unidade hospitalar
uma das maiores da áfrica que ocupa uma
área de mais de 160 metros quadrados e
serve uma porção de 9 milhões de
habitantes ficou totalmente destruído
todos os edifícios ficaram sem teto
choveu no interior o blá
é inoperante o que complicou o impediu a
prática assistencial não apenas a quem
estava internado mas também é tudo
aquilo que era necessário socorrer
resultante da cadastro do herói e as
famosa se não podia ficar ao lado do
desafio de colaborar com a população de
abelha e o ideia aconteceu numa
quinta-feira no domingo a seguir quando
em portugal não se falava ainda ser
habilidade porque não gosto comunicações
com a cidade mais de 45 dias aí ao
famosos em colaboração com a ordem dos
médicos reuniu e criou o movimento no
trabalho desde o ventre as pela beira
teve dois grandes objetivos o primeiro
foi prestar apoio médico e medicamentoso
aos colegas do hospital central da beira
afinal de contas um hospital de
retaguarda crucial e assumindo que tenha
havido uma ajuda humanitária incrível
uma resposta mundial brutal no poste e
dai o significa na emergência nós
assumimos que tinha muito mais lógica
para as qualificações para
a apoiar no pós emergência e o mês de
maio durante o dia inteiro devo uma
equipe a trabalhar com os colegas evitar
central da beira que levou mais de duas
toneladas de material médico e
consumíveis e teve a preocupação de
fazer formação em áreas de tecnologia de
gestão de serviços dos registos
transversal a todos os profissionais da
higiene e segurança alimentar crucial em
qualquer ocasião mas particularmente
numa época em que as epidemias eram o
grande drama e do pessoal de enfermagem
a formação era sempre uma formação ombro
a ombro com a base teórica mas uma
partilha de conhecimentos e competências
e tivemos o privilégio de criar alguma
coisa de diferente por exemplo criar uma
unidade de queimados pediátrica
moçambique em moçambique são tudo no
mato à noite as crianças não têm
cobertores e da época seria a forma de
sá que seria dormir junto a fogueira e é
óbvio que acontecem frequentemente
acidentes com queimaduras
é mas as tensões corporais brutais essas
crianças são internadas em uma
enfermaria no serviço cirurgia de
adultos hospital central da beira e o
tratamento das suas queimaduras e que se
alguém já se queimou um pouco e tu sabe
a dor de uma queimadura e grande parte
das vezes tensões corporais enormes o
tratamento das queimaduras apenas
perfeito com mudança em um analgésico
sem nada carregador as dez e meia da
manhã passar no corredor de serviço
cirurgia identifico com mais de 20
crianças sistematicamente internadas a
fazer os seus clientes sem nenhuma
analgesia e as famosa em colaboração com
os profissionais do serviço criam
protocolo de seda analgesia afinal
simples mas que é preciso saber que ele
existe e saber utilizá-lo e que permitiu
que uma forma de administração oral de
fármacos é partir da o do dia da
implementação deste protocolo era uma
tranquilidade passar naquela enfermaria
sobretudo porque ensinamos as mães com o
apoio das enfermeiras a usar a medicação
e por mim
as crianças que enviam no pânico do dia
seguinte do peso do dia seguinte
passassem a ter tempo para brincar e
pudessem desenhar e relaxar e ter um
olhar bem mais sereno bem mais tranquilo
mas permitiu também aos profissionais de
saúde senti nesse muito mais confiantes
e capazes e muito mais reconhecidos pela
possibilidade de poder ir tratar sem
infringir dor e tratar de uma forma
muito mais eficaz por muito incrível que
possa parecer a humanização nestes
hospitais é algo que não existe o volume
de trabalho é brutal a dificuldade de
acesso a ferramentas para tratar grande
parte das vezes enorme o que significa
que a pessoa o pensar na pessoa o
preocupar com o sofrimento da pessoa é
algo nem sequer faz parte do raciocínio
do dia a dia é preciso resolver a taxa
de natalidade como referi é
incrivelmente elevada com 5 a 6 gravidez
para cada mulher o que leva a
internamentos às vezes de crianças em
mais do que um ano mesmo
e me leva na sequência depois falei da
falta de humanização outro aspecto
impressionante a joaquina teve seu sexto
filho teve o sexto filho para o caminho
porque eu estou 40 km para chegar ao
hospital devo seu sexto filho a caminho
do hospital foi um bebê prematuro aquilo
que ele está tem um termômetro ao lado
para ver a dimensão tinha sim um pouco
pouco mais de 600 gramas e que foi para
uma unidade de cuidados especiais
unidade de cuidados especiais essa seria
o equivalente a nossa unidade de
cuidados intensivos neonatais onde seria
ventilado se houvesse ventilador mas não
é não a teria um tipo de assistência
diferenciada mas não existe foi colocado
num berço apenas e foi disparado que o
bebé sobrevivesse entre em conta a sua
resistência maneira aqui que eles queria
que eu queria partilhar o nosso pior
possa joaquina que quando chegou ao
hospital já que seu bebê nos braços
prematuros com 60 gramas foi avaliada na
ginecologia e que volta e o seu bebé que
foi internado nesta unidade não tinha
direito a visitas ou seja
os bebês internados em unidades de
cuidados especiais não vi o seu é
durante internet e nós encontramos a
joaquina depois do segundo dia estar
sentada à porta da unidade da pediatria
e sem ter visto o seu filho e
conseguimos nessa altura implementar um
processo ou projeto que permita que as
mais todos os dias na rotina do serviço
consigam visitar os seus bebês
internados que pelo menos durante meia
hora porque não só podiam ter acesso ao
seu bebé e saber o que passava com ele
depois da criança ter alta para além do
apoio médico e medicamento ou seja a
famosa subiu reconstruir hospital
central da beira um dos maiores
hospitais da áfrica e o para que os
falei e que terminamos a primeira fase
de reconstrução e recorda 16 imagens
anteriores em novembro iniciamos a
reconstrução a 16 de maio dois meses
após virar e a primeira fase que incluiu
três blocos foi terminada a dia um de
novembro e a reconstrução dos três
primeiros blocos destes grandes grande
hospital da áfrica incluiu o bloco
cirúrgico incluiu
e incluiu o bloco de uma cirurgia que a
partir de 1 de novembro começar o seu
funcionamento em pleno o banco de sangue
ok de uma cirurgia nunca pararam de
funcionar o bloco cirúrgico deixou de
operar desvirar e recomeçou as cirurgias
a partir de novembro iniciamos a
cobertura do grande bloco das
enfermarias do hospital central da beira
que tem dois mil metros quadrados e que
vamos impermeabilizado para imagens do
interior do bloco operatório que faz
inveja alguns dos blocos do nosso país e
do serviço de imagenologia e do serviço
de sangue estamos neste momento em pleno
desenvolvimento da segunda fase de
reconstrução com mais três blocos e
vamos avançar a partir de março ou abril
para a terceira fase de construção do
hospital que vai incluir a construção do
bloco das enfermarias cujo estado
exterior é fácil daqui ser avaliado e o
estado interior onde são internados
todos os doentes no hospital e eu lembro
que drena cerca de nove milhões de
habitantes está neste sábado
é porque reconhecemos que é fundamental
dar capacidade de se ver alguns
recém-nascidos vamos apoiar o
aparecimento da primeira unidade de
cuidados intensivos neonatais em
moçambique e por que o nosso cor é a
formação pretendemos desenvolver e criar
o primeiro centro de salvação continuar
no país
e entendemos que ser médico é nobre ser
médico e usar as suas capacidades e
competências em prol dos que nós
tratamos aquilo que nós somos formatados
e aquilo que nós sabemos e gostamos de
fazer ser média que usar as nossas
capacidades para as vezes com pequenos
pormenores notar essas competências o
conhecimento de colegas nossos ávidos de
saber as condições acusado em ter acesso
a esse mesmo de saber e sabendo que
pequenas mudanças resultaram na melhoria
da qualidade e desperta
a roçadeira é algo pode vir garantidos
em seu coração e justifica a páginas da
vida está ligada e
e aí